[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes del
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo mi nombre es juliette riaño y los
acompaño desde casa
[Música]
el más reciente informe global de acnur
sobre el desplazamiento en el mundo
durante 2020 revela que el 42 por ciento
de las personas que huyeron de sus
hogares fueron niños y niñas y en un
contexto de pandemia donde los países
pobres albergan al 86% de las personas
refugiadas los derechos básicos de los
menores sociales de educación y
psicológicos corren el riesgo de no
recibir atención
el desplazamiento particular de menores
se puede prolongar durante años y por
eso en los lugares de tránsito o
refugios temporales se toman medidas
para dar respuesta a sus necesidades a
méjico durante los tres primeros meses
del año llegaron casi 3500 menores
provenientes en su mayoría de
centroamérica allí encontramos una
iniciativa para que los niños puedan
estudiar mientras sus familias esperan
una respuesta a sus peticiones de asilo
las profesoras también son solicitantes
de refugio
y alma beatriz dicta clases desde su
casa a niños solicitantes de asilo en
méxico
un teléfono móvil es la única forma de
comunicación que tiene con sus alumnos
algunos incluso ubicados a 90 kilómetros
de distancia en un campamento de reynosa
claro en dónde yo me desempeñaba dando
clases verbal frente a frente con los
niños
nunca nos imaginamos la verdad llevarnos
y había
el encono sumo en este caso una
experiencia nueva porque no es lo mismo
estar frente a
a la pantalla de un teléfono a este
frente
bastante es el alma emigró pero como sus
alumnos y familias quedó varada en
mexico y no ha podido seguir su viaje a
eeuu que me va a escribir así una
historia que comparte con anna otra
maestra solicitante de asilo que enseña
a los niños varados en las ciudades
fronterizas mexicanas advierte que la
educación virtual es la mejor opción
para que los menores se pongan al día en
sus estudios no sé por qué motivo razón
de 8 años no pueden leer no pueden sumar
de 10 de 11 o sea un niño prácticamente
a la edad de 89 años que tiene que saber
multiplicar tiene que saber dividir lo
básico no sumar restar a leer
tanto habana como alma hacen parte de
sidewalk school una escuela a distancia
que nació de la iniciativa de otra
docente preocupada por la situación de
los menores en tránsito sin educación
teníamos niños mayores que no sabían
leer ni escribir era un problema cuando
la escuela era presencial en el
campamento de matamoros porque los niños
se iban era vergonzoso incluso cuando
intentábamos decirles que iban a ser los
ayudantes de la maestra no querían pero
después del cobi pudieron apagar sus
pantallas y nadie sabía que estaban en
el jardín de infantes funcionó bien con
la ayuda de 300 tabletas side box uno
llega a 700 jóvenes de 4 a 18 años en
nueve ciudades fronterizas en méxico
cuánto es 9 + 6 a kilómetros de mexico
en jordania una contadora de historias
busca a través de cuentos retratar la
realidad del campamento de refugiados de
esa atari y entregarle a los niños una
visión de su realidad que incluye
problemas pero también soluciones amarra
chiles refugiada y realiza trabajo
social con los menores a través de la
narración oral una tradición en su natal
siria en el campo de refugiados de esa
tarea en jordania el segundo más grande
del mundo una mujer siria redacta y
cuenta historias
comenzó a hacerlo como terapia propia
pero luego produjo cuentos ilustrados
para niños que conoció en el campamento
siempre escucho a la gente hablar de
problemas siempre estamos insatisfechos
quejándonos de la guerra siendo
refugiados no hay agua no hay
electricidad así que pensé por qué no
deletrear estos problemas y convertirlos
en historias que sugieran una solución
al mismo tiempo para que los niños no se
vean afectados por ellos la vida como
refugiados no es simple y lleva una
carga adicional para los más pequeños a
veces sin educación o apoyo emocional en
una pequeña habitación asma mantiene la
atención de un grupo de niños y es que
ellos son los protagonistas de sus
cuentos en la imaginación del mundo nos
hemos convertido en un simple número el
número de refugiados es tal o cual
escuchamos en la televisión sobre los
refugiados que viven en el campo desatar
y diane y nos hemos convertido sólo en
palabras
objetos números pensé por qué no
demostramos nuestra presencia una por
eso espera empoderar a los niños para
que el mundo no los vea sólo como una
estadística no tenemos pasatiempos que
perseguir tenemos sueños tenemos mucho
lo que aspirar y debemos aumentar
nuestras ambiciones según dice 2.5
millones de menores sirios desplazados
hacia países vecinos necesitan ayuda
humanitaria y 750.000 no van a la
escuela
la situación de los niños refugiados en
el mundo merece especial atención
miles vivieron el desplazamiento y otros
alrededor de 1.000.000 nacieron en
calidad de refugiados algunos incluso
corren el riesgo de permanecer toda su
vida en el exilio hasta que inmigrantes
de france24 recuerden comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]